i don't need reflections i need the
lighting this is the only tool i need
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so it's no secret that i'm a big
fan of 360 cameras in fact the very
beginning of this whole vlog series
started with me trying to build a 360
camera rig using gopros and 3d printed
parts but time has evolved right and now
we have all kinds of 360 cameras look at
this we have the rylo the insta360 one
this old gear the ricoh theta s but
there's a reason why this camera has
been my favorite camera this year so far
the insta360 one because it allows you
to actually choose your framing after
the fact so you can just have this on a
selfie stick walk around just recording
you don't worry about getting the right
angle and that has been great because we
can incorporate that into these videos
that you're watching right now and the
feature that makes that possible really
is the stabilization which is something
that is actually quite unique to 360
degree cameras it operates the same way
that a gimbal does to stabilize a camera
where you know it stabilizes the
rotation in all three axes but for a 360
camera it sees everything so if the
camera does this you just stabilize it
back like that so you'll end up with
weird flickering moments because the
world is being stabilized but the camera
has recorded motion blur so the motion
blur stays in place where the image
moves it's not perfect but it's getting
there imagine how good this stuff is
gonna be in like five ten years i think
this is like 360 cameras oh
i'm so excited for the future you may
have actually seen the video we did
recently where we actually put this on
an arrow and shot it from a bow and that
was really cool it gave us some really
interesting unique footage but why am i
talking about this today insta360
announced a brand new camera called the
insta 360 one x and this is it
one of the most important things for me
as a visual effects artist with the 360
camera is using it for my renders
longest time the only thing i was able
to do is use this to just take a single
image and that's just for reflections
but that's not enough i don't need
reflections i need the lighting so i've
actually been in talks with the people
from insta360 and i managed to convince
them that this was a good idea to
include bracketed exposures so it'll
take multiple exposures from really dark
to really bright then i can combine
those in photoshop to make an hdr no
other camera none of these cameras can
do this okay this camera can but it's an
annoying process i have to buy like a 10
app to work with it these can't do it
but this one will be able to now why do
vfx artists use hdris well it's because
it alleviates the need to
recreate all the scenery of a real world
scene instead of replacing each of these
lights with a 3d light in my 3d scene to
try to replicate the exact visual uh
situation of the scene you could just
use an hdri and that is literally just a
giant light package all wrapped up into
a 360 degree image so i can have a 3d
model here that has all the proper
reflections but not just that also the
proper lighting you get the proper
highlight so if you were to expose down
on this image you would still retain
detail in the skylights and the light
bulbs whereas everything else is black
or you can do the opposite where you
raise everything up and you start seeing
all the fine details in the shadows
whereas if you're exposing for the
really bright stuff that'll just be kind
of black you have the entire spectrum of
light all wrapped up into a single image
file it's super useful for making 3d
images more accurate quicker and cheaper
so as a visual effects artist this is
the only tool i need when i go on a set
and i need to like recreate the
environment for a 3d model i don't have
to bring multiple cameras i don't have
to bring a big
dslr and tripod and do this really
lengthy process of stitching together
all these images so if you are a vfx
artist and you're looking to get a
camera to take environmental photos for
your cg renders this is the camera to
get and you use hdri's exclusively to
light your scenes right um well
sometimes yeah
this one is mainly lit from htri i have
a um just an area light to like give me
a little bit extra but most of it the
color and the lighting is yeah from an
hdri from a grayscale gorilla yeah
because they make it really hdri link is
what you're using right i'm using hdri
link yes but if you want to use your own
hdris we can use this camera and film
our own and you can still import that
into hdri link i have always wanted to
know how to do that i've never done it
i've never done it's really easy sweet
heck yeah yeah remember uh when i did
that that spacex video and the whole
like
leg came out of the wall yeah i used my
own hdri filmed right there nice yeah so
now we can do that much easier with this
camera
now physically it's a little bit
different than the one obviously this
thing tend to rolled around a bunch we
have a bigger sensor bigger optics
overall leads to a much better quality
image it has this door on the side that
actually lets you have a removable
battery so now when you die on the field
when the camera dies on the field you
can just replace the battery and uh keep
going hopefully you continue to exist so
on the other side you'll notice that
there's a micro usb port here connect a
cable that goes directly to your phone
whether you have an android phone a
pixel or an iphone whereas before on the
one it had a built-in lightning port to
plug in directly to the phone that was
kind of cool and all but it limited you
to only using iphones now i can download
the images from the camera to my phone
really really quickly over wire or let's
say you forgot the wire guess what this
has wi-fi i haven't had this camera
super long but i am really excited to
continue using it for all my one-wheel
adventures because when you put it on a
stick it looks like no one's holding the
camera that's my favorite part about
using a 360 camera like this i mean
someday i think this will be the only
camera i ever need to use and they will
probably be built into our phones to be
completely honest what's the future of
cameras the future can oh okay yeah i
want to talk about this in the video
soon but i think the future of cameras
are flying disco balls stay tuned and
subscribe to find out what i mean by
that now to go into something completely
unrelated we're going to do a movie
challenge and see who can guess what
movie is playing based off of just the
audio
after the smashing success of last
week's guess that movie challenge i have
been relegated to the position of host
for my poor performance we are here to
find a challenger for the champion nico
the contestants are going to have to
guest five films correctly i'm shaking
[Applause]
wow
impressive
[Music]
matrix
steady people let's finish
[Music]
terminator
alien
alien two aliens yeah oh
damn soon are you live yeah friend ren
was so close on that booty dude fine
four three
guys
[Music]
agent down
not
[Music]
get ready get ready get ready for the
biggest hit of all time
oh my god i want to watch that movie i
just it's still interesting
is the best movie in the world it's
michael bay at his peak
peak michael bay it might be a short
competition smack it down carmichael
rush hour
spider-man
jurassic park jurassic park
extended that's super short we're gonna
have to extend this one there's no way
they're gonna get it well i'll play it
one more time
if you don't get it we'll skip this one
um
uh
no what's the name of that movie
um
[Applause]
this is a blowout sale water this is a
slaughter what are you guys doing i'm
trying dude i'm getting rid of this
chair so i'm standing up it's in the
music that's on its own oh the music
yeah the music okay that's funny that's
funny
you gotta get some of this action movie
dude you're gonna have to pick up on
unconventional cues i've seen a lot of
action movies
that's why you think so i'm gonna win
i don't think i'm gonna win with that
mindset with that mindset you ain't
gonna win nothing son i think i'm gonna
win because i feel like it okay when i
was in college i used to go i was on the
cross-country team we used to go running
for like at least an hour every single
day and all we would do would be quoting
movies is that did i say that sentence
correctly
we would do all we would do was quote
movies
all right ready
logan
alien x-men
terminator
oh boy
you guys oh man man okay
so impressed that this is a great
selection of films here
this is a like if you haven't seen any
of these movies so far
go watch them immediately all right here
we go let's just stand back
to where i was
all right keep you good keep those ears
sharp
thunder
it is hard to hear you guys i've never
seen deadpool so oh good i was like
we gotta spice this up with more
superhero movies that's the only way
clint will get me thrown is this there's
more superhero movies
if gabe takes the cake here i'll be very
impressed
here's here's one that is very even you
guys all have a shot at this
[Music]
[Applause]
yes i recognize that sound design
[Music]
good man the other night's tale
[Music]
last samurai
uh oh uh braveheart
dude that's that's a good one
gladiator
oh hot fuzz wow
[Applause]
it's the end where he comes in with all
the guns and he's on the horse
[Applause]
i was just guessing movies that i knew
there was an action star with a horse
it's just the sound of a horse going
clip-clop clip